on the hill tonight for the giants will
be the veteran right-hander johnny cueto
35 years old and his 14th year at the
big league level this is what he has
done this year
six and five with a 4-0-1 era adam
frazier who leads the national league in
batting average
right to the first baseman and wade
takes it to the bag frazier is retired
nice change up two and two the count to
hayes
hit hard to right field yaz out in the
sunshine out number two now brian
reynolds another pirate's all-star
a high fastball hit to center field not
deep coming in as duggar and he'll make
the catch and that's a strong start for
johnny cueto retires the pirates in
order one two three take a look at
cool's numbers overall they're pretty
good but man of late he has really
turned it on e.r.a is coming down fast
here's lamont way junior 2-2 from cool
and he could not hold up wade wendt on
that down-and-in slider he struck him
out so cool fans wait to begin tonight's
first inning here's yaz
and cool strikes out yastremski we're
coming right after him yeah fastballs
late sliders yeah those sliders are
effective again arm speeds up that
slider's really biting that's a it's a
good start for chad cool tonight no
question that that is his best pitch
under third base and two outs struck him
out on that slider down in the zone
three strikeouts in the inning for cool
nothing nothing second inning here's the
o2
called strike three on the outside of
fastball nagowski's complaining that was
right on the corner i don't know why
he's complaining
right there statcast said so the
eyeballs said so maybe it had enough
movement coming back to the corner that
he just read that as a ball all the way
but that one definitely got back to the
plate one out that's the first strikeout
for cueto polanco who's three for 16 in
his career against cueto
and lines this one toward the right
center field gap there's triples alley
and can polanco leg out a three bagger
oh he's gonna try looks like maybe a
hesitation gamma will certainly score
and it is a trip
trip
triple for gregory polanco in a one
nothing lead and that's a nice triple
again with one out not only knocking in
the run but
now he puts himself in the perfect
scoring position right down the middle
up mid thigh
yeah that deep corner the ball gets out
there you're not going to stop a guy at
second very often his second triple of
the season as it scores gamel so that
lead-off walk has turned into a run and
the chad's bringing the infield in now
for jacob stallings
that is all for stallings big strikeout
for the second out so two down and up
comes kevin newman
here's a half swing did he go yes he did
says las diaz that's right three cueto
gets three strikeouts in the second but
he also gives up the run
the way you saw keeper ryan hayes line a
single to left he's there with two outs
at first base hey still getting a decent
lead at first throw the first close play
looks like we're gonna get a challenge
on the play oh over there it's very
close it looks like he got his hand in
there before all the angles that they're
showing looks like the tag was a little
late just an interesting time to
challenge you got two strikes with two
outs with a man on first base reynolds
is a dangerous yeah but a man at first
with two strikes all right here comes
the call from new york safe
it's just an interesting time to
challenge i thought two strikes on the
battle two outs early in the game now
watch nells hit the ball in the bay
and now
brian reynolds crushes one the former
giant prospect
goes toward the mccovey cove and a
splashdown for brian reynolds an anchor
down
talk about clearing the deck with a
cannonball and it is three nothing i
guess they made the right decision
trying to challenge not wanting reynolds
to hit but yeah two outs two strikes and
reynolds comes through that's a big time
clutch home run 3-0 the way cool's
pitching right now that's a big lead
steven duggar to lead off here he'll see
another 3-2 pitch here it comes
that ball high and deep to right field
and goodbye
into the water i guess he's feeling all
right steven duggar with his seventh
home run and the giants are on the board
it's three to one pirates steven duggar
man i hope he is all right that swing
certainly made it seem like he is thank
goodness he convinced gabe kepler to
leave him in the game john nakowski
since becoming a pirate came into the
game hitting 412.
plato gets the strikeout on the high
fastball fifth strikeout for cueto and
here is gregory polanco polanco strikes
out swinging strikeouts hitting the city
for quite a both on fastballs two down
nobody on a couple of strikeouts for
quito here's jacob stallings first pitch
swinging to right field yostremski there
and that's a nice quick one two three
inning for cuedo here's the left-handed
hitter dickerson he's the possible tying
run one out one on
he blasts one to right field polanco's
gonna turn around and watch this it's
gone
up onto the top of the wall
to tie the game at three
tenth of the year for alex dickerson
and we got a tie ball game
and take a look at the hanging slider
that is right at the belt and that's
what you're supposed to do with them
and another example the carry to right
field tonight this ball hits right
on the metal roof above the levi's
landing
and that my friends is a four bagger
hits that green roof it's a home run and
that is not cool out of the game
loaded here's adam frazier now pitch of
the game right here's the inning that's
going to decide who's going to win this
lays off and it's a bases loaded walk
pirates get the lead back they walk the
guy trying to sacrifice bunt now walks
the guy where the bases level and the
pirates lead it four to three and now
ben gamel
and camel bounces it to first
oh bobble
a drop by wade and two runs are going to
score
wow
wow
giants who pride themselves on great
defense just had a huge blunder as wade
could not handle a routine ground ball
by gamel a two-run error as frazier
takes nothing for granted he's flying
around third right now look at that
that's the ball player incredible what a
break so lamont way junior the jets need
another base runner to be able to send
the possible tying run to the plate in
the ninth inning one and two
into the gap right center and it gets
down and all the way out to the wall
rough scores
wade heading for third a stand-up triple
down to his final strike the giants down
to their final strike and he hits a
triple into the gap in right center
field and jastrimsky will come up as the
possible tying run well the giants down
in the ninth two and two
and it is right there called third
strike raised to jolly roger yestremski
airs out estabrook the pirates
defeat the club with the best record in
baseball coming into tonight